for the media it was therefore March
Madness the wheels of change are
happening and I'm getting chills just
having this conversation just north of
the National Mall where women's suffrage
started in civil rights there's really a
handful of marches that when you
remember that our town remembers the
civil rights marches of the sixties to
abortion rights marches for the 80s and
90s Tea Party Million Man March I think
about those things
this is right up there these young
people are very much like the anti
Vietnam protestors in the early said the
late 60s it was the beginning of a
protest so what was once personal is now
political complete with slogans signs a
gushing media militant salutes
and of course invective first off I'm
gonna start off by putting this price
tag right here as a reminder for you
guys to know how much Marco Rubio took
for every students life in Florida one
dollar and five cents that was harsh but
was it daring not really what would be
daring is including a Parkland student
with a different viewpoint on gun
control up on that stage as well
now with David Hogg he's just a kid
right so the media says off limits but
the Rubio thing that was lame
grandstanding is that too harsh to mr.
Hogg not really because by criticizing
him I'm complimenting him he's now
revolutionary like other well-organized
and well-funded revolutionaries not
challenging revolutionaries would be
patronizing but if you're asking me the
students from Parkland had a real gripe
a craven Sheriff didn't do his job as
well as an insane killer did his so 17
people died the students thought their
school should be a safe space not like
the safe spaces of older college kids
who weep at the hint of painful truths
but a real safe space protected from
madmen and when necessary shielded by
grown-ups with guns the same goals of
sensible students should not be ignored
by the NRA but if the other truth is
ignored by parents will go on blaming
guns for acts of evil instead of actual
evildoers and in four years you will end
up with cowering under gray
majoring only in sanctimony and
sign-making there was a great story
after this killer Mike who's an amazing
rapper did an interview with the NRA
with Collin or about why his kids
weren't marching let's roll that I told
my kids on the school walkout I love you
if you walk out that school walk out my
house we are we are a gun owning family
yeah we are a family where my sister
farms we're a family where wheel fish
will hunt but we are not a family that
jumps on every single thing I a live
ours does because some stuff we just
don't agree with now he had to apologize
for that one do you think he should have
apologized for what did he apologize for
for what he just said he had to
apologize for saying he wouldn't allow
his kids to go to that March was that
right for him to apologize I don't think
so I can't he I mean I don't did he say
he was gonna punish is that what he was
saying he wasn't going to allow his kids
was he apologizing because people said
you're engaging on your child's right to
express their opinion no he apologized
because he realized he went against the
I guess the forced assumptions of his
friends about that I mean he can say I
mean I think there are people who
especially people who live in rural
parts of the country and as he was
saying you know our custom to hunting
fishing and all that who are much more
comfortable with guns but that's not the
issue we're talking the issue here is
what happened in parkland what happened
in places like Columbine now almost 20
years ago would happen at Virginia Tech
Newtown that's what we're talking about
and to me you know I'm just struck that
people will try to diminish the power of
what happened over the weekend the
incredible turnout the incredible
numbers not just in Washington but
around the country of people trying to
express you know something's wrong and
we need to really have honest
discussions and confronted like I was on
Fox News Sunday yesterday with Newt
Gingrich the former speaker says to me
who's paying for this and I think do I
what you so you question the
authenticity the sincerity of these
young people or to say as you were
saying today
why aren't they mad at sheriff Israel
and I think to myself well you could be
mad but that's the heart and soul of it
is that we see repeat
occasions in this country of this kind
of incident and also don't forget the
ongoing attacks in places like Chicago
that we often discuss where handguns are
used to you know by the gangbangers and
they like to kill people and I just
think it's time for us as a society to
be dead willing and daring enough to
stand up and say we're gonna deal with
this we're gonna stop having easy access
to guns every week well I mean there's
the strictest gun laws in the country in
Chicago and it's the deadliest city or
at least one of students well I mean
wand guns get everywhere you can always
blame it on somebody else Indiana the
Russians that's not the point
what is it's good that they had a March
I mean I'm glad to see students active
and not playing video games and you know
I mean that you want people involved in
democracy and that's fine what's wrong
with video games just get outside get
some sunlight that's all I'm saying but
there are a lot of contradictions at the
rally there was one rapper who was
performing that he was arrested last
year on a weapons charge or there was
one of these guys Cabot Phillips who's
like a younger version of me that went
out and asked questions what's an
assault rifle and no one knows what an
actual assault rifle is and all these
people are being protected by heavily
armed security guards that's fine the
guy is a david hog or hogs
he started off and i've seen him on fox
news he started off as this balanced
nice kid who was reporting the facts
about what were happening at the school
and he's just now become a real bomb
thrower and someone like this i think
isn't helping the conversation it makes
people get their backs up this guy makes
people think you're coming for my guns
you're gonna say that rubio is you know
has blood on his hands because he takes
money from the nra maybe he takes money
from the nra because he supports the
Second Amendment it would be more
scandalous if the NRA was buying off
Democrats and they were voting for NRA
legislation even if they didn't believe
in it so that that doesn't make any
sense to me I also think that whenever
there is a scandal in this country the
left in the media blaming Republicans
it's the NRA
it's Fox News it's Trump its Bush no
matter what happens because in this
particular situation the guy had a rifle
because the Bill of Rights said in 18
with no criminal record can have a rifle
and it was the police and the school and
the FBI those are the people that failed
let's just take a broader look and not
just target the NRA
you know Kimberly the thing that
troubles me is how there's it will it's
an explicit point that you cannot
challenge someone over this kind of idea
because they're teenagers which to me is
the opposite of education right if they
enter the realm of debate you respect
them by engaging you don't respect them
by simply saying you're right right I
mean you've not supposed to coddle them
if they want to engage in public
discourse and debate I applaud their
desire and their ability and their right
to do so therefore there must be healthy
debate on the other side as well and I
do see there's a bit of a backlash with
David Hogg's B's almost now to the point
where as boomeranging to help the NRA
because that March for our lives is
becoming a little bit tangled in with a
gun grab motivation which is highly
problematic so there's you know
interesting dialogue and rhetoric going
back and forth in communication which is
fantastic and they were marching out you
know here in New York in front of my
apartment this weekend the whole deal
and you know it's good to see people
getting involved that's what we want
that's what we fought for our freedoms
for this country but nevertheless we
also fought for two halves our
Constitution and to have our Bill of
Rights and the Second Amendment is
healthy and it's robust and there are
protections you know in place so listen
we'll see what happens
the fallout you know from this but it's
not just like it's it's not too smart to
just focus on the guns themselves yeah
Dana is is is it possible that the cut
the kind of incendiary rhetoric
validates the law-abiding gun owners
fears that it's not about bump stocks
it's about confiscation when you see
people up there saying I don't want any
guns it depends on where you sit yeah so
that's what if you are a gun owner then
you probably you could be definitely you
could see it that way this isn't you
don't get a march like this about the
balanced budget amendment no this is
about passion and I do think that there
are attitudes that are changing about do
something they don't necessarily know
what that is and so some of the
solutions
to somebody that understands it more so
I was like well that won't work exactly
if you're constantly as a scolding
saying that won't work and that won't
work and that won't work then you're
missing kind of a point I think there's
a there's a movement happening here I
don't know if it will last maybe
something will change but I do think
that you see the the the attitudes
changing and so in one of the things
that the president did so well he's got
that power to convene and no one's gonna
turn down an invitation to come and talk
and it might be that he could be the one
to bring some NRA folks together and
some of these March for our lives folks
together and say let's get in a room and
let's talk about it even if it doesn't
lead to a solution maybe we could just
calm the tension a little bit yeah I
mean it's it's you the first step is you
feel something and then the next step is
that you want to do something but in
between
you should read something because
there's so there's so much literature
out there about gun control that a lot
of people don't know about and if you
just take two hours David French has a
piece up that just posted on National
Review it's talking about guns planing
yeah and and that why it makes sense
because there actually are facts right
health and so if you're looking for one
article to read that would be